uh with that i'd like to introduce our
our first speaker kevin johnson the ceo
of juniper networks kevin
so
you took over three years ago um and you
know in in the context that i just gave
this the the uh the notion of a network
networking equipment etc was i would say
a relatively well understood thing and
then suddenly everything changed from
the economy to the rise of these trends
that we've just described
in the last three years how is your
vision of what a network means and how
you play and it changed
well i think you know clearly you
pointed out that a lot has happened on
the web over the last 20 years i mean 20
years ago i think there were 100 million
users of the world wide web today
there's 2.1 billion
eight trillion dollars of of commerce is
transacted over the internet on a global
basis
you've seen trends like facebook go from
zero to 600 million users in a seven
year period
and so the last 20 years has been this
sort of foundation for what people
expect and the network now is woven into
the socioeconomic fabric of the world we
live in
but the three market trends that you
highlighted mobile internet cloud
computing and this video tsunami that's
taking place
those three trends are accelerating and
those three trends i think will be the
mega trends for the next decade
those three trends
have significant implications on the
network and and other aspects you know
will the legacy approach to networking
be able to carry the volume of traffic
efficiently and enable these scenarios
uh policy questions around things like
net neutrality
uh new business models that will emerge
and so i think we're at this inflection
point where
there are a lot of
opportunities for innovation a lot of
need for innovation and a lot of
questions about how this will unfold
over the next decade
and so that's where we as a company have
been focused
of those three um some of them represent
opportunities and others threats let's
start with the the threats what what
worries you most when you look at the um
really unexpected inflection points
we've just encountered
but as for as a company
well
let me just start as an industry and
then i'll translate that to to our
company but as an industry over the last
20 years there's been economic incentive
for
the investment in capital to build the
infrastructure to carry this traffic
and that economic incentive is is a
function of certainly the revenues that
service providers have derived from
internet data connections and in the
capital investment required
the analysis we've done though says that
traffic is just increasing at such an
exponential rate and even with the pace
of of uh innovation that's taken place
over the next decade
you know we think there's an inflection
point where
investment starts to exceed the revenue
derived and so economic disincentive
is
is a potential risk that the industry
faces
so the questions are can
technology companies innovate at a
faster pace to carry the volume of
traffic
uh can innovation enable new business
models and new services that that you
know address unique needs for consumers
and businesses and you know how will we
you know continue to address this
insatiable demand for people to be
networked
and so i think there's a lot of
opportunity
for the industry and i think there's a
lot of risk if the industry doesn't rise
to the occasion and sort of embrace the
fact that
uh
new approaches are required to handle
these trends
it's often been said that we've been uh
coasting over the past decade over the
on the over investment in infrastructure
made during the first.com bubble um all
that dark fiber that was laid and you
know with
nasdaq you know
money and all that
it's now said that we're in a new bubble
but the difference between that bubble
and this bubble is that
a it doesn't have the same sort of
public market
volume and b it's typically not focused
on data infrastructure itself
are you cons what will the funding
sources be for that next required
you know massive investment in in the
physical networks itself
well
in in a
free economy an open economy it has to
be economic incentive it has to be
people will invest because there's
opportunity for them to get a return on
that investment
and you know so there's there's plenty
of capital to go you know
there's access to capital to make these
investments but the question is
is there the economic incentive so
it's part of you know the risks and the
opportunity for a company like juniper
we've got to be leading edge innovators
in a way that differentiates the
approach from the legacy network and
unlock value for customers we've got to
find ways to continue to reduce the cost
per bit of traffic that that is carried
on these networks we've got to find ways
to address the cyber security concerns
that can become a barrier to adoption
we've got to find ways to enable new
scenarios that
that recognize you've got more
untethered mobile users that are are
demanding and and want to participate in
more scenarios like video and online
gaming and so we've got to be at the
forefront of enabling those scenarios
and we can't do it alone we have to do
it through an ecosystem of partnerships
i mean we're focused on a certain
element of innovation
but we recognize that innovation comes
from from a lot of different uh places
and so being a member of that ecosystem
engaging in the dialogue
uh sharing the innovation that we have
embracing the innovation that others
have we think that by creating that
environment we can we can at least play
a role in contributing to the solutions
to some of these challenges
let me focus on the shifting mobility in
particular um what we saw with the fixed
with wired internet the fixed line
internet is that um by and large the big
last mile providers the comcast of the
world are dumb pipes that's all we need
from them is is pure bandwidth
and we pay we pay handsomely for it i
think it's a good business but it's a
dump pipe we're not looking for them uh
for for you know we're not going to
their websites and expecting them to
provide you know the uh the the the
content and the internet content that's
there's transport
um the cell phone carriers however have
traditionally been much more value-added
networks
you know they're that we we pay them for
services and traditionally we have um
had go through them for
you know for for many of the features um
as we shift to the
iphone model um the ipad model etc do
you think this that the wireless
networks will become smarter or dumber
well first of all i think comcast might
disagree with you with their investment
in nbc universal i think they they would
argue they're more than dumb pipes in
terms of the content and
the video assets they bring to the table
but
you know certainly every service
provider is focused on a unique strategy
that's relevant to to them and i think
for
you know your question about wireless i
think clearly my view
in working with service providers around
the world is they're driving an agenda
to have the wireless services they
deliver become smarter and a richer set
of services
and it's not just about carrying the
traffic it's about carrying the traffic
and enabling a set of scenarios that
that delivers value to the to the end uh
the end user whether it's a consumer or
business
and so there's a lot of innovation that
is happening in service providers to
experiment with new scenarios and
deliver new services and some of them
will work and some won't but i think the
trend is for smarter networks well i
certainly understand that's what they
want but i mean in detention you know
the apples of the world would like these
services to be provided by the device
itself so that voice and you know
voicemail being a perfect example
voicemail wants to be a you know visual
voicemail on the phone an internet
provided service the carrier would like
voicemail to be a service on the network
you pay for in that tension between the
device makers and the networks
themselves how do you
predict or plan for who will win yeah i
don't think you can plan for who wins i
think it's a it's and i think that
tension is healthy because that's what
drives innovation it's competition it's
it's whoever invents the best scenario
you know the consumers will vote
you know with with uh their choices in
terms of who services they use and what
they sign up for and
you know if the consumer says hey we
like the
you know the comcast video offering or
they say hey we prefer apple tv with
netflix or you know we have a
playstation game console that delivers
our netflix video i think you're going
to have a range of of
offerings and at the end of the day that
competition is healthy it's a healthy
thing because that's what will lead to
innovation
let's turn to the living room
now
the the the rise of the sort of
connected television that's connected to
the the smart tvs the game the xboxes
and and um the uh you know dedicated set
top boxes etc are you would you predict
that
five years from now
people will have in fact cut the cord
and be getting all their content over ip
rather than paying for dedicated cable
services
well first of all the the the digital
video or ip video consumption that's
happening today statistic i saw earlier
this week was 80 percent of that is now
being viewed on television sets
now certainly the fact that netflix you
can get netflix uh streaming video to
your gaming console or
you know being built into tvs the tv
still is the preferred device for people
to view video
um
and the distribution of that video is
all shifting to ip it's the it's the
it's the most
cost effective way to deliver that
volume of data in a
a user on demand scenario and so you
know
our experience is we see every service
provider working to converge networks
and shift everything to an ip packet
switch delivery of that content well i
guess i'm thinking more in terms of the
two parts of my bill you know the cable
tv part of the bill and the i and the
internet service part of the bill
what sort of shift do you see there am i
going to are we going to see more people
sort of saying you know what i'm going
to cancel the cable tv part and just
take it all over over over internet well
i think for the next five years you're
going to see both i i watch the video
over the top but i haven't canceled any
of my cable tv
choices either so
i pay for both uh and maybe i'm an
atypical consumer but
in our household
we pay for both you're still typical and
i i think the actual trends are really
on the margins at the moment but the
direction seems seems it seems to have
that way but there is there is the
scenario of here's the video you want to
watch on demand whether it's a
television show that you didn't watch
live or or
a movie that you want to download the
convenience of that
is uh is a very nice thing and that's
not going to go away that's going to
that's going to increase
for sure and so then the question is
you know will people continue to to to
consume
other video services that that they
consume today and i think i think
they're going to consume both
let me ask turn to the last trend the
cloud
between google facebook microsoft amazon
and now apple's
icloud service how does that change your
world
well
in eve every one of those cases those
those companies are building massive
data centers to
do the compute and storage and deliver
those services
and
that you know whether you call that
cloud computing private clouds or public
clouds
the inflection point of how technology
comes together to enable those scenarios
is a big opportunity for us
and the reason the market moves that way
is it's it's it's driving economic
advantage first you centralize then you
virtualize which gives you better
utilization of assets and then you
automate and by doing that you can
deliver these phenomenal scenarios from
a more central location at a much lower
cost
but in order to do that it's creating
opportunity for how all of those devices
are connected together how they're
managed
the
speed and performance the reliability it
creates it creates questions about
security you know how do you secure you
know cyber security i think and privacy
will be two of the top
policy issues and considerations over
this next decade and how do you secure
those scenarios uh how do you enable
them at high high performance high
reliability and so in every one of those
cases
you know those are all customers of ours
that we're engaged with helping
with solutions and and finding ways to
advance the state of the art in cloud
computing
i mentioned at the start uh that uh
you're now doing this job for three
years um we've talked about what an
interesting time this was to take over
and how
and how many uh
are happening simultaneously which
what's been the biggest surprise for you
over the last three years yeah
probably the the speed at which
the mobile internet has has shifted over
the last three years and
you know and i kind of look at the the
inflection point that the iphone created
the just the innovation around the touch
capability on the screen the ability to
have a full browsing experience and then
all of the new content consumption
applications that followed so
iphone android ipad this tablet
explosion you know if you just track the
adoption of smartphones versus feature
phones over the last 10 years and then
look at the last three years
the data i saw that shows this year that
smartphones will now exceed shipments of
feature phones which
the tipping point occurred in the last
24 months
and at the same time
this
transition for video is occurring so you
have two major
uh
inflection points of consumer behavior
happening that is driving huge demands
in the technology infrastructure
and i think the surprise was that
happened during this period of a
recession when you would have thought
you know okay
when the econ you know macro
economy you know goes into some
challenges in 2009 you would have
thought okay that's going to slow any
technology trends or consumer trends no
it actually accelerated some things and
that was a surprise
one last question i'll make it a quick
one um
i we've been talking about the sort of
the transfer of services to ip and uh
skype is a great example of this as you
know microsoft has bid to uh uh to uh to
buy skype if you were steve ballmer what
would you do with skype
if i were steve ballmer what would i do
with skype well look if i invested 8.5
billion dollars in in a technology i
would make sure that that technology
gets woven into every user experience
that it can that could it could be
delivered whether it's on xbox
on windows on windows phone and i would
also look to to leverage it as a way to
to bootstrap a set of complimentary
cloud services you know it's you know
the basic communication whether it's
voice or video teleconference
communication
is a core asset that you can now build a
set of things around and you know
certainly they've got a set of assets
that i think are very complementary to
it but it'll be a question of how well
they integrate that and start to to
really change the paradigm of the way
that people connect and communicate and
collaborate
terrific
please join me in thanking kevin johnson